and how do you think American audiences
will respond uh I think and audiences
universal how how did i respond to
american films as born in a village in
south of India but it worked for me I
mean I could understand chaplain with
all that knowledge in the language my
linguistic inabilities never came to the
fore when you watch great actors and
even not only Chaplin and at 17 when I
was an assistant director nobody told me
that Citizen Kane is a film that the
greatest American film I found it to be
so I discovered Dalton Trumbo on my own
so I think good stuff is international
good stuff is universal and I hope my
mind is good stuff too you've mentioned
previously that sometimes audiences or
something to be feared that as a
filmmaker sometimes you're so paranoid
of what the audience will think that you
get out of it yeah that's I think I
copied that line from Chaplin but that's
not truly my think a chaplain says it's
a multi-headed monster you don't know
how what it'll think I don't think so
but i think it's it's a slightly
different replication of myself as an
audience I make films that I really
would love to see and I do it honestly I
think the audience would be my family
and they like it and because we think
alike and I've realized over time
watching other people what great
filmmakers try to become after they
achieved the greatness is to regain the
naivety of an audience the open might
not even naivete is not the word the
innocence of the audience without
technique which surely emotion and they
try to get back into that like how we
think of childhood actors I mean act
directors try to get back into that
position of an audience which according
to them is the penultimate position to
be the audience
when you've achieved climbed the ladder
to the full extent then what do you want
to do is reverse the ladder climb again
right so not to judge well this cut was
bad or start looking at the edge of the
frame if the camera shakes a bit a
filmmaker notices if if it goes slightly
askew he knows it but a true audience
doesn't care it doesn't care who care
whether the cameras gone Dutch
topsy-turvy well it's just a feeling
that they get and they watched the
center of the frame and sometimes a good
director can make them watch whatever
corner of the frame he wants the
audience do that that's when he truly
becomes an audience himself and he knows
what watch in a frame the focus shifts
automatically the camera moves towards
the subject and the the audience are so
satisfied because that's exactly what
they wanted to see and off the whole
scenario and that's where the camera
goes forward it's a very satisfying
feeling you're mentally nodding to
yourself yeah that's what I wanted to
see and that that's a great directors
work
you